les italiens capitulait les allemands
battaient en retraite se dirigeant
lentement vers l'ouest nous faisait
violemment voyez chaque centimètre de
terrain en temps et ensemble
[Musique]
il y avait des patrouilles les snipers
des mines terrestres
continuer quand même on mettait
prudemment un pied devant l'autre tout
en tenant nos fusils on faisait notre
possible pour rester vigilant malgré
notre détresse mêlée à la confusion et
l'épuisement ont continué à avancer seul
dans les décombres de la guerre et ont
continué à être puni pour ça j'évoquais
de coco c'est beaucoup d'allemands
marsanne très léger prenez à steiner et
heisman avec vous n'a aucune idée de la
taille de leurs forces
vous n'avez qu'a vous confondre avec les
arbres ou qui portent aux couleurs c'est
l'un des nôtres du tout irait bien
on va terminer cette mission cette
mission suicide c'est un peloton
d'exécution
mais qu'est-ce qui va pas chez toi rhin
[Musique]
j'ai pris ma décision je vais rapporter
tout ce qui s'est passé sont plus du
tout les jambes au bout